good morning we now are going to have a
talk by Joe Stiglitz on the issue of the
youth bulge the subject of our day I
think probably everybody in this room
has heard or read something that Joe has
written or spoken he is a very very
prominent figure on the world stage an
advisor to governments all over the
world an advisor to to NGOs the people
who think about global issues his
background is there's no need to go
through it of course he won a Nobel
Prize and he was a chief economist at
the World Bank and chair of the economic
advisors in the White House joined this
faculty in 2000 has had a very big
impact here follows a long line of very
distinguished people in the Economics
Department and in global issues one of
the things Joe did we set up a committee
on global thought to try to encourage
faculty both to think about global
issues but also to provide a place for
non-traditional people to join the
Columbia faculty and that's been very
successful he was the founding member
for that founding chair so Joe's a real
person on the international stage and a
great person here at Columbia I think
the main thing I would say is that every
time you you talk to Joe you learn
something and you always learned it in a
context where there's good humor and
there's a real sense of wanting to have
an exchange he's a forceful advocate he
gets away with the enormously
controversial statements because he's so
charming
and I'm constantly getting calls from
distinguished people and powerful people
say can't you control this guy and of
course I say I will and then we work on
anyway he is that he's a real a really
interesting mind and it's great that he
would be here this morning to begin this
discussion joke well thank you very much
for that introduction although I never
thought I ever said anything
controversial Avett XY can get away with
it anyway the subject of this today's
discussion the oath book youth bulge I
want to put it into a little bit broader
context which is the impact of
demographics because as some of your
notes that you wrote in response
indicated in some countries there is a
youth bulge but in other countries
excluding the other way and the general
point is that demography the changing
demographic composition is going to have
an impact on almost all countries and in
some countries it's going to be a youth
bulge in some countries it's going to be
youth shortage but we have two in one
way or another deal with this changing
demography the youth bulge is
particularly serious of course in in
Africa and a a continent where where
there was already enormous challenges to
developing their educational system and
so it compounds the problems there and
next to of a number of of the other
countries where there are today today
facing the youth bulge what I want to
first make a couple of just very broad
comments about
how demography the change in demography
has some very big effects on our economy
our society that in one way or another
have to be taken into account and
particularly by educational institutions
one aspect that's actually a very
positive aspect is that the nature the
dynamic nature of an economy is related
to the fraction of young people in the
population that one of the things you
can think of you you're all used to
thinking of companies having old
equipment or new equipment and a company
that has new equipment is going to be
more dynamic more able to face that
vicissitudes of the economy what the
same thing is true about human capital
as it is about physical capital and the
there this is probably even more true in
a context of the very fast changes in
technology so the the natural way that
younger people interact through Facebook
through through IT has given them a kind
of networking capacity that is very
different from for motor people so the
positive side of of a youth bulge is
that the economies that have this
younger demography have the opportunity
to be are likely to be actually much
more dynamic much more lively societies
of course for those of us who have a
bore aging society that's a problem
because we at worry about ossification
having the people making decisions being
people that are a little bit out of tune
with new technologies and with the
the bulk of the population which are the
younger people coming along there's
another problem that is becoming
increasingly important in those
economies which are almost economies of
the world where there's a LOX where
there are serious problems of
unemployment because the some people
occupy jobs and some people want to
occupy the jobs that other people occupy
namely the young people would like to
get some of the jobs that are presently
held by us and that's uncomfortable
position for those of us who want to
have our jobs occupied by others but
there's a broader issue of distribution
that comes in when it gets reflected for
instance in the united states where the
the if you have a housing bubble which
is a thing that we had in the united
states and a number of other countries
had young people today don't have the
wealth to buy houses in the way that
young people 30 40 years ago a very
large fraction of young people in the
united states now are living with their
parents very big change in patterns of
living and this is beginning to raise a
whole set of you might call
intergenerational issues
intergenerational equity issues in
economies like spain where there's been
some rigidities in the labor market
these problems can get very highly
focused because young people see a lack
of opportunity because old people are
occupying the positions not only a power
but also just the plain jobs the result
of this is that in a country like Spain
the youth unemployment rate now is
the official statistics report the youth
unemployment rate around forty three
percent but when you adjust those
statistics to take account of the fact
that large numbers of people have
dropped out of the labor force large
number younger people stop looking for a
job because there aren't any and in the
unemployment statistics you don't count
somebody who is not looking for a job as
unemployed of course they're not
employed but they're not treated as
unemployed and if you make that
adjustment the youth unemployment rate
in Spain today is over fifty percent and
that's obviously a serious problem and
not only for the youth but I think for
Spanish society and there are similar
problems in some of the other countries
of Europe like Ireland that are facing
economic downturn so if we go back to
the Arab Spring to the profit to the
protest in Tunisia that brought out that
began the Arab Spring most people
commented that one of the factors was
the high level of youth unemployment the
lack of opportunity to lack of Hope in
many cases of getting a job but there's
another factor that also played an
important role and that was access to
the jobs that were there were viewed as
unfair those who had connections had a
higher probability of getting a job
regardless of whether they were the ones
who did best in school and so this issue
of equity is an extraordinarily
important one and the concerns about
equity have resonated around the world
they were part of the donatos movement
in in spain
and part of the Occupy Wall Street what
motivated those protests were not just
lack of jobs slow economic growth but
also a sense that there was something
unfair about our societies and that our
political system not only wasn't not
only was in our economic system
functioning as it should but our
political system wasn't addressing the
problems both of the economy economic
function and of the underlying
inequities in our society the reason why
i want to emphasize both of these is
because when it comes to universities
universities are one of the mechanisms
by which we give opportunity to those
who otherwise wouldn't and i think it's
going to be very incumbent on
universities to try to to cry to create
fair access fair access to places in the
university and then to play a role in
making sure there's fair access to the
labor market after people graduate
before talking about that i want to talk
a little bit more about the unemployment
problem that is facing many countries
around the world and as you all know
well the whenever the unemployment rate
goes up almost always it's the youth
unemployment rate that goes up much more
so that in the united states the youth
unemployment rate has typically been
twice the level of that of the average
unemployment next the same thing in
spain and many other many other
countries that means of course that from
the point of view of national economic
policy it is imperative to try to work
to get the unemployment rate down that
that is the first order is very hard to
deal with youth unemployment if you
aren't dealing with the overall level of
unemployment
it's going to be very difficult in the
current context to deal with that
problem in the United States in Europe
it's easier to deal with the problem in
China and some of the more dynamic of
the advance and dust of the emerging
markets but even in countries that are
growing very rapidly like India growing
was growing at nine percent now growing
around seven percent the problem is that
the growth and employment hasn't always
kept pace with the growth of GDP and
that that that again leads to the
problem of opportunities for young
people so let me talk just a minute
about why I think there is this this
problem of unemployment my ex become so
pervasive in particularly as a youth
unemployment for the United States and
Europe the fundamental problem is lack
of aggregate demand we've not managed
our economy well and in Europe it's even
worse because they are cutting back in
government support and that will lead to
a lower level of aggregate demand a
higher level of unemployment Europe has
already entered into a double-dip
recession and while the leaders of
Europe keep talking about optimism I
think they are really set on a course
that is likely to make things
significantly worse if they didn't get
worse it would be necessitate are really
rethinking some of our economics so I
you know I from an academic point of
view I that the likelihood that things
will turn out well out of this
particular austerity venture is very low
even the United States though
has been engaged in austerity the number
of public employees now is about a
million lower than it was at the
beginning of the recession so while in
our textbooks we always say the
government is supposed to make up for
the deficiency in the private sector in
fact government has been exacerbating
the problem and unfortunately the
politics and uniting stakes are not
likely to make this to reverse this the
real risk is that it will get actually
worse so this problem of unemployment
and therefore of youth unemployment is
going to be with us for I think sometime
they'll be a little you'll read in the
newspaper something about green shoobs
manufacturing as increasing X through
manufacturing is about ten percent of
the labor force so a little bit increase
in manufacturing is a good thing but
it's not going to solve our economies
problem and the fundamental problem a
fundamental issue is that what kept the
economy going before the crisis was a
real estate bubble that helps support a
consumption boom savings rate in the
United States went down 2-0 that was not
sustainable and it wasn't sustained and
now it's up to four and a half or five
percent and it's likely to remain there
every once in a while with somebody the
administration or the Fed will say the
consumers coming back not likely to
happen and we shouldn't hope what
happens because that would be
irresponsible consumption and the other
part was to say the real estate bubble
forty percent of all investment was in
real estate but we overbuilt and so now
we have a problem of a legacy of over an
overhang of excess housing the good
thing mm was the houses were very
shoddily built
and it won't last that long so the the
normal length of time I'd be 20 or 30
years are this this this will last quite
as long but uh the the it will take a
long time and that's why it's more than
deleveraging that's at stake even after
de leveraging the economy is likely to
remain weak we may start to grow at even
three percent three three-and-a-half
percent but that's not fast enough to
make a dent in the 23 million or 25
million Americans who would like a
full-time job and can't get one and so
even if we grow it won't be enough to it
to really reverse the problems so that's
what's happening in the United States in
Europe on the side of China and India
and both of these there's a growth
slowed down a lot of them there were a
lot of discussion of a hard landing I
think that's not true and a lot of
discussion worry you know the sort of
long faces as growth slowed from nine to
seven percent as if it was the end of
the world anybody from America or Europe
if somebody said that we could grow at
seven percent we would be jumping for
joy and it shows you how how your view
of what is good or bad is affected by
your history seven percent is very
impressive economic growth and part of
the discussion Britain China for
instance is that it's more important to
have you might call high quality growth
sustainable growth equitable growth then
have very rapid unbalanced growth and so
in many ways once you've welcomed the
slowdown but I particularly in India
where there was a problem of keeping up
the growth the the problem of jobs for
the growth wasn't fast enough for
creating enough jobs for four people
moving from the rural area to the urban
area that slowdown presents an even
greater challenge one of the reasons
that there has been such problems in job
growth in many of the emerging markets
is that one of the sector's where
there's been there have been very
successful in China for instance is
manufacturing but manufacturing has been
experiencing enormous productivity
increases and the result of that is that
even if output is going up up very
rapidly there are no jobs are not being
created so one of the things that most
people don't under realize is that
manufacturing jobs in China are now
lower than they were a decade ago there
is no growth in manufacturing jobs in
China even though its output of
manufacturing has been growing
significantly that's an important
warning or important point for economies
all over the world many of whom seek to
become larger in manufacturing there
will I think be a movement from China to
other countries in manufacturing but
even though though as wages in China go
up even though there is that movement of
output the number of jobs that are going
to be created will be very limited the
global economy today is a service sector
economy for those of us in education
that's a good thing education health
tourism culture all kinds of things like
that we are moving into a service sector
economy and that will be true not only
of the advanced industrial countries but
increasingly also of emerging markets
that's important as we think about what
kinds of skills will kinds of education
we ought to be delivered
to up to our students so the economy and
this is very I'm going to come back to
this economy in both the advanced
industrial countries but even in
emerging markets it's going to be going
through Rapids restructuring and we have
to teach the skills a kind of education
that will enable students to to meet the
new structures of the economy that will
be emerging the final preliminary point
I want to make before I turn to the role
of the University in a little bit more
detail is the issue of aspirations of
what kinds of jobs that people seek and
that's a real problem in in many
countries in Middle East but all in
other other air places where you see it
very vividly in these countries where
you have high unemployment but at the
same time large immigrant populations
you have economies where there are jobs
but the people in the country don't want
those jobs and they asked people from
other countries to take the jobs that
they don't want so you have this this
mixture of economies with high levels of
unemployment and high levels of
immigrants coming in and then I think
has to do with aspirations of what are
viewed to be acceptable and good jobs
and that problem goes back I think to
education not just well before the
university and even to our societal
values some countries faced up to the
problem or at least begun to talk about
it and realize that for instance that at
the elementary and middle and secondary
school education is oriented to urban
jobs
moving people from the rural to the
urban sector but in many developing
countries seventy percent of the people
live in the agricultural rural sector
and that will probably be true you know
it will even in 20 years it will be
fifty percent so if you've trained
everybody to the mindset that they have
to get the only good jobs are urban jobs
if your whole education system is
oriented to focusing on on good orbing
jobs it's not likely that there's going
to be enough good urban jobs for all the
people aspiring and going through the
education system so I think we have to
think we have to think a lot about how
do we get people to accept that there
are good jobs that are very different
from the the ones that have
traditionally been the ones they aspire
to civil service jobs or or you know
everybody would like to run all the
large corporations be president of
everything but an economy needs workers
and and one has to somehow deal with
that that is a particular problem in the
United States I think we'll be at a
particular problem in the United States
for young men I think there's a gender
issues they're going to become
increasingly important the reason why I
say that is in the United States there's
been a hollowing out of the middle class
jobs that you went two young men the
jobs in manufacturing the jobs and
construction what I've destroyed those
two sectors of the economy are arguing
hollowed out and wages are going down
number of jobs are disappearing and the
jobs that are going to be available are
going to be much going to be very
different kinds of jobs and the young
men will have to if they want employment
will have to accept that was well let me
now talk for a few minutes about the
role of the University in all this
as I say obviously universities are
absolutely essential in preparing young
people for the labor market they also
play a very important role in what we
call the wealth dynamics one of the
concerns that occupy wall street raised
was the high level of inequality the
fact that the upper 1% of the United
States Garner's Forex elf about twenty
percent of all the income and has about
forty percent of all the wealth but even
more troubling is the fact that not only
has the United States become the most
unequal the most unequal of all the
advanced industrial countries but it's
also become the country with the least
opportunity the likelihood of a you know
United States likes to think of itself
as the land of opportunity horatio alger
if you know you know the stories of how
people brought themselves up by the
bootstraps are sort of you know the
hundred books were written about Horatio
Alger stories they are important part of
America's sense of identity but the data
show it's a myth America has at least
the least opportunity of all the
advanced industrial countries and the
reason for that almost surely has to do
with education our education system has
been providing less opportunity for
those who are less affluent and that
comes because for a whole variety of
reasons we can talk about that it goes
back to elementary and high school that
you know the highly selective
universities like Columbia have not
needs buying a mission they say anybody
can get emitted no matter what the
income of your parents and will pay for
the difference except it's a remarkable
a statement and it's a remarkable
commitment that they provided but the
fact of the matter is that the students
who make it to getting the good s80
scores the good high schools the good
performance are overwhelmingly in the
upper twenty percent of our population
the fraction in the bottom fifty percent
is minuscule and that's even after
efforts to correct that imbalance and so
we have to realize that we have this
problem of what I call wealth dynamics
in the United States but X true in other
countries as well and unless we counter
it it could get worse and if we don't
Connor it that there's an interaction
between adverse what I call adverse
wealth dynamics and increasing
inequality in our society and that leads
to the problem that I said in the
beginning a sense that the system is
unfair and when you have societies that
are unfair of high level of unemployment
you have thing you have a recipe for
instability now one of the particular
problems I talked about just a few
particular problems now facing
universities one of the particular
problem is facing universities in the
context of high levels of unemployment
is that there's pressure for skill based
education and Columbia College augment
to amherst college these are schools
that have been committed to a liberal
arts education are very broad education
I believe that those kind of broad
education is very important for adapting
to a very quickly changing economy and
society but the students are typically
more sure excited they want the skills
to be able to get the jobs right away
and so I think one of our challenge will
be to
to meet the demands of the students to
have skill based education but to do it
at the same time provided them with at
least a core of the liberal arts
education that has I think the
foundations of a long run success the
second broad issue that all of us are
going to be facing is that education is
a service sector and it's a high school
service sector wages the cost increase
faster than have been increasing in the
United States and many other countries
much faster than median income and
that's even worse than the United States
because public support has been
diminishing next also true in many
European countries that means that there
is an increasing problem of accessing so
the cost of education is going up faster
than median income and that that means
that people at the bottom will have less
and less opportunity for getting the
education that they need well that books
a very heavy burden on universities to
think about how they can control costs
and you know they try all variety of
ways I think it's a major issue but
basically the way we deliver education
hasn't changed a great deal and you know
the delivery of other products has
changed a lot but the delivery of
education hasn't now in some ways at the
core of successful education are the
inner are the close personal
relationships between a teacher and the
students but one of the one of the
responses to
increase in cost is they have larger
classes which is of course undermining
that close relationship the second
problem is if we are going to be facing
the problem of access we want to be able
to take into our schools students of
heterogeneous background and if we have
large classes that will become let we
would be less successful in providing
education it's not just a question of
admitting them it's actually making sure
that we can deliver an education that is
responsive to their backgrounds so what
I think we have to do is to think a lot
more about the structuring our education
so as an example I think schools like
Columbia amorz need to have many more
smaller classes the first two years to
adapt to be able to deliver the kind of
education necessary for a heterogeneous
population coming in but then we have to
think about how we can use technology to
supplement some of the conventional
teaching and there have been big Vance's
and technology younger people what I
said before is younger people are used
to technology in a way that some of the
older you know we resist reading some of
us resist reading a newspaper and on the
Kindle young people they don't like
paper and it's good for their forest
besides but but the they are much more
adaptive to these new technologies so it
seems to me that as we focus on cost
focus on efficiency focus on the
importance of access I think we need to
re-examine the whole issue of the
delivery of our education and we have to
agree examine the content as we as we
think about the the issue of designing
an education system that is good for
their
long life after school but also gets
them a job in the short run in a very
competitive marketplace okay we try to
have this be as conversational as
possible so just questions for for Joe
yes I suppose so okay thank you for
sorta stiglitz and thanks for professor
Ballinger for hosting this event I have
two quick questions the first one is
about the social cost of the youth bulge
and what's the role of the right
information or precise information on
reducing such a cost if you could
elaborate on this place the second
question is you said that the problem is
cutting the aggregate demand and you
know that we have at least two schools
regarding how to get out of the
recession some of the countries who
suffer from chronic budget deficits the
cut aggregate demand and also they
expand or they use expansion monetary
policy so they have mixed tight fiscal
policy and expansion monitor both do you
think that this is a wrong or is not the
right policy to get rid of rescission
thank you the second one is an easier
question for me to answer because exist
the answer is that that in Europe and
America today there is no scope for
monetary policy so there isn't in normal
times you can have this mix between
monetary and fiscal policy you can have
fiscal contraction and monetary easing
and that can stimulate the economy right
now with interest rates at zero
it's very hard to get more monetary
easing QE 2 didn't work it caused a lot
of disturbances in some of the emerging
markets important point here in the
nature of globalization most of our
Theory most of our models focus on a
closed economy and in a closed economy
you increase the money supply that leads
to more credit in the country and that
stimulates the economic activity that's
no longer true in our global open
economy because the United States lends
more but it lends to say companies say
the Fed opens up the the spics and money
goes into some American companies but
the American companies are global and so
what do they say where is the best place
in the world to spend their money and
what have they decided not in the United
States the best place to spend the money
is Brazil China India the economies that
are growing so it's not so so the the
the monetary policy is not going to work
now the other argument that is sometimes
put is that lowering the fiscal deficit
will restore confidence there is no
evidence that that kind of restorative
confidence will ever lead to more
investment in higher GDP but we cutting
back leads to lower GDP and that
undermines confidence there is one
mechanism that countries can use and
that is to raise taxes and raise
spending in a balanced budget way and
that's something called the balance
budget multiplier and if you raise your
taxes the right way and spend the right
way it can be quite large unfortunately
a lot of the discussion United States is
to cut taxes and cut spending which is
having exactly the
negative effect now your first question
on the social cost of the youth bulge
what I tried to emphasize is it really
depends on how we respond to that youth
bulge if we fail to create jobs then the
cost can be absolutely enormous because
it will lead to unrest it will social
disturbances of all kinds if on the
other hand we are able to educate all
these young people and get them jobs
you'll wind up with a younger labor
force and I'm more dynamically before so
we could actually have a positive effect
now one of the final points is that the
sectors that if you have a youth bulge
the thing that you need to expand is
education in most countries education is
primarily the responsibility of
government in one way or another
especially if you want access you know a
fair access and that means government
policies that are cutting back are
working exactly in the opposite
direction to the restructuring you need
and the education that you need to
respond to the youth bulge let's say
let's use the microphone in the back
Michael first and then sorry and then
we'll bring a mic to you rather than
stand up so that I mean you don't know
people don't have to come up to the mic
there's a mic coming and just thank you
very much Joe thank you for those really
informative and insightful remarks about
the challenges that are especially faced
by universities in the US and Europe I
think it's directed right here to us at
Columbia's of congratulations that we
should be hearing all of that my
question is how much of that translates
to other parts of the world that are
fifty or seventy percent rural where
there is very in some cases very little
agricultural productivity
which means that agriculture is not
providing the demand that it could
otherwise provide for the economy or the
stable and growing food supplies that
countries need what rule could
universities play in that kind of
environment where the real challenge is
rural and uneducated agricultural labor
can universities play a role there or is
it beyond beyond their reach I mean
works didn't what you might say yeah
what I tried to hint at is that not only
should our elementary and secondary
education in these economies be more
focused on the reality that most of
people will be in the world of sector
but also the university's next year in
the United States we celebrate the 150th
anniversary of the passage of the morel
Act which created our state agricultural
land grant colleges and universities
these universities raining you know
Cornell Texas AM you know Iowa all all
the key universities around the country
played a vital role in increasing
productivity in agriculture and leading
to the transition from an agriculture
economy which the United States was in
the 19th century into a modern economy
so very strongly our universities you
know agricultural universities can play
a very important role in particular not
only they play a did our agricultural
universities play an important role in
training they also played in a training
University people they also interacted
with the communities that they were
located in and with through what we call
it extension services that increased
productivity in the areas around where
they located and so it was both directly
and indirectly that they had a huge
effect on our economy yes and then back
in the
world Sam Ibrahim Alexandria Egypt you
mentioned the difference between the
skill based education versus the liberal
education in actually in developing
countries like Egypt we have a third
type of Education which is a singletrack
education that leads to an abundance of
university graduates that are not fit
for the market actually so in Egypt for
example we have thousands of graduates
of the Commerce school and on the other
hand I've been involved in in many
companies that when we need to hire
somebody we have to rehabilitate him
from the start we have to give him a
different type of education that would
fit him or allow him to join the drop so
what's your advice for us should we
concentrate more on skill based try to
involve these students or early post bed
to join the market while they are still
in their education phase so so we can
make use of their force in the working
community yeah this is yeah that's a
very good question either I think that
they're there are two aspects that I'd
like to focus on for modern economy
there has to be what we sometimes call
lifelong learning that the world is
always changing and they will not if
they're trained for its job today and
they don't learn they will become
obsolete and it used to be the people
would have a job for a whole lifetime
but now they move from job to job and
that requires more and more skills so
what we need to do is two things one
have institutions that help provide that
lifelong learning you know they help
have the region you know and in medicine
you that you require people to keep
getting retrain so we have to think of
institutions that provide lifelong
learning but are in our universities we
have to think about how do we prepare
them for this process of lifelong
learning
so max we're particularly liberal arts
education is very important because it's
the myung sex excel earning skills that
are going to be critical going forward
but the second thing is that we have to
help them get immersed in the labor
market we sometimes talk about those as
soft skills and some of what happens in
the universities may be counter to that
you know for instincts in some
universities we give in to our students
who don't like to get up before ten
o'clock in the morning and that's sort
of pampering them when they get into the
labor market they don't have a choice of
saying I'll get up at ten o'clock in the
morning you know if they're told to get
up at eight o'clock in the morning they
have to be at work every day at eight
o'clock I'm kidding a little bit but not
much the the point I'm making is that we
have to do a better job of that
transition from education to the
workplace and part of that transition
will be apprenticeships internships
various kinds of programs that get them
more immersed so I the bottom line is we
have to do more of both we have to do
more of the liberal arts but also more
of the things that we need to do to get
them easier immersed into the labor
market fo push a un two questions for
you I was really struck by your comment
about changing the structure of you know
how we teach in terms of smaller classes
in the first couple of years larger
classes perhaps and in that context I
wonder you know there's been a lot of
discussion about use of adjuncts use of
graduate teaching and some of the
difficulties with that I wonder if you
could talk a little bit about that and
then the second question you know at the
UN one of the things we're finding is
that for many of the global challenges
that we're facing what we need is
innocent systems thinking complex
thinking so it speaks to an
interdisciplinary
or a background now you've talked about
the importance of liberal arts education
that tends to focus more on linear
thinking and I'm wondering whether we
need to be thinking about the core that
we're providing our undergraduate do we
have to be changing the Nate you know
going away from so the basic education
expense into more interdisciplinary
types of courses yeah yeah both of those
good questions the on the first let me
give you an example of least one kind of
discussion that's going on in some
places there are big advance
improvements in online education there
was one course that that I believe that
was put online expand furred and had a
hundred and fifty thousand students sign
up for it just amazing and I think
something like a 50,000 100,000 actually
completed the course and you could
imagine working very hard to develop if
you have that many students that you
could put a lot of resources into
developing the best course that you
could imagine for those students but at
the same time I want to go back to what
I said a lot of Education is
interpersonal interaction so one of the
ideas that that is being talked about in
some circles for online education is
having online education but then having
centers where people meet with adjuncts
with with people maybe not at the same
stature as those people putting on the
online course but can provide some of
that face-to-face interaction answering
the questions so I think you know in the
same way that we we already inter in our
universities mix professors and and
and TAS but to try to do it more and
more thoughtfully and more more
leveraging than we've done in the past
the issue of interdisciplinary work is
something I I meant to talk about ran
out of time but let me talk about two
aspects of that one of them is a lot of
the most exciting work is
interdisciplinary and one of the reasons
it's exciting is because as you say it's
nonlinear that you have people thinking
one way confronting people thinking
another way and that interaction between
different thought processes stimulates
parks and weeks to advances at the same
time the reason we have disciplines is
because they provide discipline that the
disciplines have a particular rigor to
them so one of the challenges is going
to be providing that maintaining the
discipline of the disciplines and the
excitement of multidisciplinary
interaction and I see that as one of the
one of the challenges facing
universities going forward for
undergraduates I I went to Amherst
College where when we went to when I
went through my freshman and sophomore
year we had a core curriculum where we
have had almost no choice the whole
curriculum was designed as a package
interaction between math physics between
English humanities unfortunately in the
I don't say libertarian era of the 70s
that kind of of of core curriculum was
viewed as excessively constraining and
one of the few universities that has
kept the idea of a core curriculum is
Columbia
and I think it's a very important part
of the education and I think the
students here really come to value it
it's part of our distinctive aspect of
of the Columbia education I think going
forward I'd like to see more
universities and colleges providing a
recent option of that kind of a core
curriculum that obviously changing you
know the world today is not the same as
it was a hundred years ago a liberal
arts education today is different from
what what does a hundred years ago we
want to talk about globalization we want
to talk about you know a whole variety
of things that are different from what
we did then but the challenge of trying
to create that kind of core curriculum a
community within the College of people
from various disciplines interacting
seems to me one of the real challenges
facing universities today it's over well
you should weigh you down some of this
if you have it i'd be happy to but I
think people really want to hear from
you you made a mission to your
presentation to the issue of controlling
costs and this is something which is
really troubling for most Vice
Chancellors or presidents of
universities in developing countries
especially the public's publicly
supported the universities I think this
issue arises especially in this
universities because government fixes
fees I believe they do so because they
want to increase access to higher
education but the the negative is it
affects the quality of education
provided by these universities what
would you what we do suggest we do in
this country's well one of the things
that I guess I just you do is to lobby
the government and to try to explain
what I've been trying to explain which
is
that success in dealing with a youth
bulge success in dealing with the future
of the economy is going to require a
high quality labor force and you can't
get a high quality labor force
competitive labor force in today's
economy without a good education system
and that nothing in life is free of the
economist say there's no such thing as a
free lunch and that means it's going to
cost particularly if you want to have
access and I would again try to
emphasize why I think access is so
important it's a fundamental value but
even if you didn't think of it as a
fundamental value if you want political
and economic and social stability and
using your most using well your most
important resource which is your human
resources you'll have to have access for
everybody so it seems to me that there
there is a compelling argument that the
universities can make and in return I
think universities have to show that
they are being responsive to the needs
of society and are trying to make
efforts to become more efficient they're
not just doing things business as usual
that they are they are trying to get
their costs down and they're trying to
think about how to be more efficient and
gain access so it seems to me that that
that's the main thing you you can do the
other other Avenue is other sources of
revenue that is to say you know adult
education you know other way revenue
revenue raisers there is the
university's produce lots of things that
the market value highly and in some
cases if there are no other avenues of
money that maybe something one has to
think about more so let me ask a
question
coming at it from a different angle
drawing on your great knowledge and
expertise one of the things universities
I think the thing we do other than teach
students best is to try to think and
understand the world so we really devote
ourselves to try to figure out instead
of how the world works and how it might
work and and it's also the case that it
seems like we do not understand the
global economy and I say that in part
because we've gone through two colossal
crisises in the last decade and if you
care about employment as everybody in
this room does it would seem like you
really want to make sure that we
understand what's going on here the
reason why I emphasize ignorance to is
because I recently heard a person who
very high up in the in the central bank
here say we understood individual banks
to a certain extent but we have to work
harder and understanding them we clearly
failed you know in a deep understanding
but the bigger problem is we don't
understand the interconnections of banks
we donors and the interconnections of
the global economy and in fact Basel has
just set up a new committee on
understanding global finance as a
acknowledgement that this thing that's
been created is being created and will
continue is remain something of a
mystery and I wonder as he think about
something like this youth bulge you can
approach it by saying you know for
purposes of dealing with this massive
problem we understand pretty much all we
need to do we got to figure out how to
implement policies it's
a matter of deep research or you could
say it really is a matter of deep
research or it is as well and these are
major questions that the universities in
this room and other university should
devote themselves more to than we do and
you know this is your world I mean you
you are knowledgeable about what's
happening in the world is anybody on the
on the planet to what extent is it
ignorance the fact that we just don't
understand things that's a key part of
dealing with the problems that are here
well I guess I put it somewhere in
between I think the real danger is what
i see is complacency by some of the
people who think that they understood
things and didn't that's the real danger
and there were a lot of people i won't
name them yeah who fall in that category
yeah we understand some of the when we
say we understand some of the problems
and well before the crisis you know i
don't want to sound immodest but i've
written about some of these issues of
bank interdependence Bruce Greenwald at
the business school and I had done a
book where we we talked about how you
could have bankruptcy Cascades and and
how problem when one bank could lead to
another that was not taking on board at
all by the the central bank's you know
that they they they really ignored lines
of thought that were outside of their
narrow lens what are the implications
for universities what seems to me first
I think we we ought to try to inculcate
a spirit of modesty that you know the
world is complex we understand some
things but we shouldn't be overconfident
and the most important thing that i
think when i was in college that i was
taught is the most important thing is to
ask the right questions and part of
asking price right questions delineating
what do we know and you know there was a
sold expression the real danger is the
things that we know that aren't true and
so let me give you an example I raised
in my talk one of the issues of a
monetary policy in a world of open
economy where we expand have
expansionary monetary policy but it
doesn't affect yeah us yeah that's an
example of you know monetary policy in a
globalized world is very different than
monetary policy in a closed economy yeah
there has not been very well why do we
yeah Annalise yeah yeah that's the kind
of question that in the University and
our students we ought to be raising even
if we don't fully know the food know the
full answer it at least alerts them to
thinking about things in a slightly
different way and hopefully encourages
research now I would go back to the
previous question about how do you sell
governments on why they should be
supporting universities one of the ways
you do it is to say look there are these
important questionings that we don't yet
fully know the answer to yeah and if we
have to rely simply on the received
wisdom we're going to make a lot of
mistakes we still may make mistakes but
at least we should be on guard aware of
the things that might go wrong yep well
we're at the end of this unfortunately I
want to say two things the first is that
I will do everything that Joe
recommended that we do except for one
and that is to take on the students and
have them go to class before 10 and
that's I'm smart enough to know that
that's one you don't don't do everything
else I'll fix here the second is you can
see why it's always such a play
and a learning experience to be with Joe
Stiglitz and we're very very grateful to
him for being with us this morning
thanks Joe
you